you know when you talk about the
protests that happened in 2017
uh by some far left people at that time
like
as bad as it was i thought at that time
i actually
quite miss it because at that time it
was people
just yelling and making a scene and
trying to interrupt events
unfortunately since then political
violence has continued to devolve
not just in portland but actually
through many
american cities and throughout 2020
portland and seattle became the
epicenter of far-left
american violence
where in my home city the city you've
been to several times to speak
there were more than 120 days of
recurring nightly violence so
you're in los angeles i know there was
some writing that happened after george
floyd died
imagine what you saw there happening for
four months straight
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
an american journalist best known for
covering the antifa
protests in portland and author of the
new
already best-selling book unmasked
inside antifa's radical plan to destroy
democracy
andy no my friend welcome back to the
reuben report
thank you dave it's so nice to be
speaking with you again
last time uh we met in studio was
shortly after i was beaten
yeah uh you were you were hurting i mean
you were actually still
in in quite a bit of pain and and you
were medicated and everything else i
actually think that's probably the
the best place we can start because i
was trying to chronicle just the amount
of time
that i've known you and i think i sort
of came away of you we've
we've sort of risen in the online world
or whatever it is
starting in around 2015 or so in 2016
or 2017 i did an event at portland state
university and
and obviously you're from portland
that's where you do most of your work
and i've uncovered most of this antifa
stuff there
i did an event with christina hoff
sommers the feminist and peter bogosian
the
uh philosophy professor and antifa was
there it was the first time that they
had ever protested anything that i had
been part of
they called me a homophobe of course
they called christina
misogynist of course they call peter a
white supremacist of course and we did
an event that you know had to have a lot
of security and there was a lot of
tension and police had to escort us in
the whole thing
anyway i mention all of that because i
met you right after the event because
you were covering it and you were
you know you were sort of just uh with
all due respect my friend you
you were like a kid journalist and you
were just kind of figuring out your
thing and now you've become
the center of what's going on with
antifa so first off my
my hat off to you uh and and now that
i've talked enough to start the show
can you talk just a little bit about
that just sort of where you
started with this whole thing because
now everyone just thinks you're part of
it
but you were you were just a scrappy kid
trying to
do journalism yeah that's right dave
actually i was part of the student group
that
organized the event that invited you so
just uh
four years ago i was just this student
journalist
part of the free expression group uh at
university
who was a fan of yours and you know it's
been such a
um privilege to to not just become
better friends with you over the years
but then like to to rise up
in our in our careers and work because
it's really linked and i think you know
when you talk about the protest that
happened
in 2017 uh by some far left people at
that time like
as bad as it was i thought at that time
i actually
quite miss it because at that time it
was people
just yelling and making a scene and
trying to interrupt events
unfortunately since then political
violence has continued to evolve
not just in portland but actually
through many
american cities and throughout 2020
portland and seattle became the at the
center of far left
american violence
where in my home city the city
you've been to several times to speak
there were more than
120 days of recurring nightly violence
so um you're in los angeles i know there
was
some rioting that happened after george
floyd died
imagine what you saw there happening for
four months straight that's what
happened in portland and it's still
ongoing now
it's just become weekly but um it's
picked up speed um this week alone we
had
let's see three riots in portland
involving antifa
so so when you started seeing this right
so you as you said you were part of a
student group you invite a couple people
that
we all considered ourselves good liberal
moderates
and i remember before the event because
there was this threat of violence they
had to hide us in a room and we had a
police escort
that had to take us from one room to the
event by the way the event
ended up being spectacular it's it's
online we'll link to it in the in the
bio here and it was fun
and you know fortunately there was no
violence but people were angry outside
um do you so you that was sort of the
beginning of all of this
then over the last couple years it just
kept getting bigger and bigger and
bigger and bigger
why what was it about it that you saw
that you knew that this was gonna happen
because you've been tracking it the
whole time
well i knew it wasn't just a university
or campus phenomenon what we were
experiencing since going back to around
2015 that the
ideology that was justifying these
outbursts
of uh far-left rage and sometimes
violence on campuses
would in that inevitably spill out to
the wider cities where these
universities are and where these
students were returning to
and so and that's exactly what happened
very quickly in portland
and i think the turning point
particularly for
its moving spilling out pouring out from
macadine
into the streets was the
surprise election winner donald trump so
that just
gave an excuse for all the excesses of
the far left
to go out and wreak havoc in the name
of anti-fascism and anti-racism and
social justice and they were given
the legitimacy they needed through
the mainstream media and through
unfortunately
left-wing democrat politicians yeah okay
so for people that
just see the videos now and we've all
seen the videos of what's going on in
portland and seattle and everywhere else
for people that are sort of just
watching from the outside that haven't
been to events
you know i've been protested many times
you actually helped another video that i
was part of go viral when i was
up in canada and antifa showed up and
they were
uh protesting that woman in the in the
walker
trying to cross the street calling her a
nazi it turned out of course that her
husband was a veteran of world war ii
who
literally fought nazis uh but these are
the types of things that you've seen
over and over
for people that don't really pay
attention though that just see those
little viral videos and unfortunately
you don't see them on mainstream enough
what is antifa
see the videos i don't think truly
show the threat we're facing them some
of them do but i mean
like these extremists carried out
in interaction in my city
where night after night they were going
with knives
and guns and explosives and organizing
themselves into different
units in a marauding gang essentially
starting fires and they eventually
killed somebody
but to answer your question what is
antifa
it is a movement in ideology
and shadowy networks of people who call
themselves anti-fascists but actually
espouse
inanicus communist extremist ideology
so the re there's a lot of meaning
in their acts of violence i know it can
look kind of
meaningless without purpose but
for example the attacks on the federal
courthouse in portland last july that
lasted for weeks when they tried to burn
down that federal
facility that was because they viewed
the american criminal justice system as
a system of enslavement of racism uh a
remaining relic of white supremacy
that's why they were doing that that's
why they attacked law enforcement and
called for its abolishment that's why
they go after
property rights as well they view
capitalism as intrinsically linked to
racism and so like bit by bit they've
gone after
not just like literal institutions in
america but actually i think more
fundamentally the founding
ideals the rule of law freedom of
expression
i mean until probably most known for
their anti-freedom of expression and
that they believe
it is the not just appropriate but
righteous response
to be preemptively violent to people who
have
wrong think or spouse the wrong views
and this was
literally what many of us were talking
about for years saying you know if you
label
everyone nazis and then you say it's
okay to punch a nazi well you've given
yourself the excuse to
to basically not only physically attack
people but burn down buildings
and everything else um what do you make
of all of the
people and we we heard this a lot i mean
i heard this a lot from my own people
oh dave this is just a college campus
thing
this won't leak out into reality um
clearly they were not correct
um i wish they were right but um
we've seen i mean the
the critical ideologies that uh have
been mainstreamed in university
these are then carried into not just
gov government by people who then end up
being
advisers and staff who work on campaigns
and people who get elected to city
government
become leaders and police departments
probably the most important thing is
that that ideology then takes root
completely in journalism so if you look
in the mainstream press
you can see um what's particularly
happened at
like america's paper of raqqa the the
new york times
or the washington post and you just see
um
how um it's a
hard left political monoculture that is
extremely intolerant
and has provided so much legitimacy to
far-left extremism i mean it's these
papers who have published
these really culturally significant
opinion pieces
in news reports as well that are
sympathetic or provide a justification
for
property destruction looting and all
that in the name of
social justice online news
news sites and magazines are no better
they also
argue for the need for
violent protests so um
they're undoing a lot of what were
norms in uh are in the united states
and i think this is where antifa's have
the most success
not in necessarily their acts of
violence and destruction
which they have done so much created so
much misery from that
but actually that tenants of the
ideology have found
footing in the mainstream left and have
been giving a certain
legitimacy in society and the other
thing people have to realize
is that um for those who sympathize with
uh when i talk to people who are
supportive of sympathizing with
the capitol hill uh siege right on the
6th of january
um their response was often well for
months and months
yeah the alarm and antiques are got to
riot and respond to their grievances
with violence
and that was cheered on and nothing
happened to them so why do we have to be
peaceful
so this is the danger as well that it
creates anti-force extremism
creates reactions on the right and the
far
right that can lead to a lot of violence
and we've already seen a lot in 2020 and
i
don't think it's slowing down this year
yeah do you sense that that double
standard where when the lefties
you know burn down buildings and attack
private property and stop cars in the
street and make people
you know denounce white supremacism and
the litany of other things happen
do you think the the double standard
from the way the media covers that to
the way they covered the capital
obviously without excusing any of the
violence of the capital
that that really is is just
completely burst forth like to me at
this point cnn is not a place of
journalism the new york times
is not a place of journalism like are
you willing to go that far on that
well what made me furious in seeing the
condemnations from
journalists influential thinkers
um politicians in response to
the riot on the 6th of january is i
wonder
why they were at best silent when my
city was under siege when federal
property in portland
yeah when what those writers did on the
sixth they did
that in worst last year okay why were
they silent then
at best and then at work some of them
actually were promoting
this crowdfunding campaigns to get some
of these accused
riot suspects back on the streets right
so quite literally i mean there were
hollywood celebrities and and quote
unquote journalists
putting money in and crowdfunding to get
rioters that had done violent acts
illegal acts to get them out of jail not
that they would have really been
prosecuted in portland or seattle anyway
however i'm fairly certain if uh
you know anyone on the right if if glenn
beck or ben shapiro had done a gofundme
to get some of the
january 6 people even if they hadn't
been violent out of jail
i think it might have been taken a
little differently are you
shocked how quickly the liberals have
just folded
on this thing you you know my feelings
on this sort of that this is
what we've seen antifa do to the left is
sort of the it's the death end
of liberalism sort of and i've watched
so many of my friends just
not be able to understand that are you
shocked that liberals seem to have no
defense
mechanism against this
uh i'm not shocked anymore given what's
happened in the past
five years i mean when people
who when liberals uh systematically
failed to
really defend um what
the academy should be about that was the
first sign right if they're not willing
to defend
freedom of expression of speech in
academic institutions
i uh i don't think they would defend it
outside of that
so i'm not shocked but i think
the reason why i've become really
powerful is because they do have
many many synthesizers and supporters on
the mainstream left people who
don't understand or don't know antifa's
violence extremist audiology who really
think that these are
just merely people who are anti-cashless
who
are going out to protect people of color
on the street from neo-nazis
i think um and it's a welfare ignorance
because
um i mean yes a lot of the media has
been so
reckless in their coverage of antifa but
there's also been some good coverage
and um you know my work has been printed
in mainstream publications and all that
um but it's just i mean this
the rule that's been laid out is
essentially you can do
anything and everything including kill
for the
alleged cause of racial justice and
social justice
so when you lay that out as
like the contacts for all these things
to happen
there's no ability for the left to
really be able to counter
you know and it should be pretty easy
but
you know antifa people think that if
you're against them that means you're
pro far
if you're against blm that think people
will accuse you of being against
black americans instead of
diving into looking at what these
movements actually espouse and what they
do have you been able to break down some
of the numbers on this
like like how many of them actually are
there how many of them are
taking place you know actually taking
part in the violent attacks
versus i think a lot of the people when
i see like their sort of allies
in the media like i would look at
somebody like jake tapper i don't think
he's like a promoter
of antifa i wish he i think he probably
wishes they didn't exist
but he's the type of guy that just won't
really tweet when they're burning down a
city but if the right wing does you know
anyone on the right does anything
it's insurrection so have you been able
to figure out just like how many
foot soldiers there are versus how many
just sort of
self hostages in the media who just
don't want to get attacked
you know just sort of a general
breakdown of the amorphous
thing um so exact numbers
across the u.s would be i think
impossible to
calculate just because there's no in
terms of
a lot of these anti-organizations we
have actually no
idea how many people are involved uh in
my
book i look specifically because i got
leaked public documents internally from
rose city antifa which is importantly
antifa organization the largest one in
the us
so i can give estimates for let's say
portland
because we just we have so many um data
points of how many
of the recurring nightly rights how many
people come
and for that it can range anywhere from
as little as
50 people to thousands i noticed
consistently though the number of people
who are actually donning
their black uniforms which is part of
the black bloc
tactics um and those who are committing
the acts of violence
that numbers really even at its peak
no more than a couple hundred so
if there was a political will and that's
the
the important word is political will to
um stop this wanton extremism and
violence and destruction it can be done
easily
however the mayor um
really actually continuously was giving
sort of
um excuses for them saying like oh i
understand that we're pro
you're protesting against racial
injustice and systemic racism and just
anytime you buy into that narrative
you're giving legitimacy to their cause
so and unfortunately ted wheeler the
mayor of portland didn't just
uh it wasn't just his rhetoric he was
actually him and city council were
implementing policies
such as restricting local law
enforcement from
actually working with federal law
enforcement
when these riots were happening both
simultaneously on federal and
city property um city seattle as well as
portland bound the use of tear gas and
responding to riotous
so um so what do you think what do you
think is going on in the head of a guy
like
portland mayor ted wheeler here's a guy
who basically says to them as they're
burning down his city okay we understand
you're protesting racism then he also
handicaps
his police officers as you said he takes
away some of the tactics
they can do then antiva literally shows
up at his apartment
complex and starts attacking the
building so he has now since moved he
also gets harassed now
at restaurants there's a bunch of videos
on that kind of thing and then finally a
few weeks ago
he said something to the effect of you
know we're gonna have to uh stop this
violence
but but what do you think is actually
going on in his head does he really
believe it does he not understand how
law enforcement works is he completely
incompetent like what's going on
and not only him you've got the mayor in
seattle and a bunch of others
um i think these are people given their
extremely
um prestigious educate education
backgrounds that
they recognize that this is a fringe
violent extremist movement
but because there are first and foremost
politicians politicians um
in the case of ted wheeler who he ran
for reelection a few months ago
um they are justly afraid
of being accused of being against blm or
being against the cause of anti-fascism
i think it really comes to cowardice
so because of that they've given um
enough space for these extremists to
work in this city to the point of where
they're even afraid of them i mean ted
wheeler in january
of 2021 was assaulted by some antifa
extremist when he was eating at a
restaurant right um
this is a guy who literally has
basically let them do whatever they want
i mean that's the irony of course
yes can you talk about how blm how black
lives matter the movement is connected
to this
because i think people are are very
confused about the associations there
blm is a separate movement
and ideology in terms of what they are
trying to accomplish in the u.s but they
share
enough common goals with antifa that as
for now they
there's a partnership in my opinion and
depending on the chapter
it's more explicit than others the the
dc chapter of blm
which is one of the largest in the
country is probably the most explicitly
uh openly allied with antifa but you see
this in terms of anti-code will
volunteer to be
security for these blm
demonstrations and that's why they're so
able and easily able to co-op these
demonstrations and to turn them quickly
into riots that's happened in
minneapolis um you know all it takes is
the breaching of a business a shattering
of a window and then
you know you already have a whole bunch
of agitated thousands of protesters
um a lot of them will take the
opportunity to loot
and then once that's done uh samantha
will then just throw in a molotov
cocktail and burn
the building to the ground um but uh
the cross pollination and ideology is
important the
intersectional um ideology
of blm has cross-pollinated with
antiphos anarchist communism
so the traditional antifa going back
decades now didn't
did not historically espouse the the
sort of
hierarchy and total polls of oppressions
that you see
in a contemporary movement like blm
however they share that in common now
and for that reason that just gives
antifa
another yet another mantle and shield to
deflect from because now they're saying
you know they're not just
against fascism they're against um
police brutality against black people um
you know that the chants are exactly the
same as the blm
chance and whenever you see auntie for
graffiti
and messages calling for police to be
killed you will see black lives matter
and blm britain
as well so as of now i i consider them
at least in american context
linked entities yeah would uh
is there an example of of a mayor or a
city that has had the beginnings of one
of these uprisings that has
has responded properly i can't
i can't think of one but i i suspect
maybe somewhere in in texas
or florida maybe
yeah so well um
it's primarily been a red states who
have responded better and quelling
um violence that was getting out of hand
um
just because even if it occurred even if
the riots were occurring
like in a liberal
progressive city um like austin let's
say
or um phoenix or something
um they're still under republican for
leadership as a governor so you know
there's the
um the use of the national guard is on
the table and all that
but even so they've been pretty well i
think
um wisconsin later on
seeing when there were riots breaking
out in kenosha which
unfortunately resulted in deaths
they were able to shut that down at
least after several days rather than
weeks because well they were able to see
what happened
in neighboring minnesota before and what
was
currently ongoing in portland and
seattle
but yeah it's it's
in terms of like a blue city and like a
blue
uh city council in mira i struggled to
think of any that
responded very well immediately and
early on
yeah so you know we started by talking
about that first event in portland state
well then i saw you
about a year and a half later in
portland again
i saw you when i was on tour with jordan
peterson and again we didn't know each
other that well but you
we met right beforehand you said oh i'd
love to sit down with jordan for a few
minutes
and i was able to get you backstage to
chat with jordan i
i believe that there is a connection
somehow between the message that jordan
was putting out there of clean your room
and take responsibility for your life
and all of those things
and the counter to that the sort of
nihilist destruction that these people
brought did you
because there were especially a portland
that was probably our biggest protest
seattle we had some but i think portland
was probably the biggest one
at least in the united states there was
also in amsterdam a pretty big one but
um do you see that that the message that
jordan was talking about
of of personal responsibility was so
counter to them and that's
that's really why they hated him so much
even though i would go out there
sometimes with a cap
and sunglasses and talk to them and they
usually didn't know why they were there
protesting or
they would just be out there and angry
and they weren't sure what was what
yeah um i think uh
it's uh it's been a shame that um
because of
uh dr peterson
was ill and was out of the public space
for a few years now
um you know we really um
could have benefited i think publicly
from his uh
wisdom and voice on everything that was
going on i think
ultimately um
for a lot of the because they really
they really hated him i mean
you know they they really were were
mobbing us online the whole thing
i think for a lot of the henchmen type
people who are involved announcing
street violence their hooligans
the ideology message that they have
internalized is completely
antithetical to the message of
self-responsibility that dr peterson
espouses so these are people who
um instead of cleaning their room or
getting their lives in order
and many of them are really vulnerable
people people who are dealing with
mental health issues you'll see a lot of
them
recently transgendered many of them are
vagrants and all that
so instead of being given a message of
improving
their own lives and the people around
them
they chose to they have been pulled into
a court-like ideology that teaches them
um
that they um to resolve their grievances
um
through violence not not just against
other people but against society in the
wider world which is why
the only thing that they are actually
good at is destruction and creating
misery
when they seize territory like they did
in the capitol hill autonomous zone in
seattle
chaz all they were able to do was create
an area that led to attempted rape
multiple
homicides shootings fights um
lawlessness yeah and and the mayor
of course let it happen until they
started showing up at her house and then
she got rid of chas
pretty quickly wait can you talk about
the the transgender element to that
because you know you often post pictures
of some of the people that have been
arrested and it and it's very clear
a lot of these people as you said
they're vagrants many of them seem like
they're
on drugs or addicts of some kind or
another but the transgender piece
seems sort of interesting because we've
all seen pictures and videos
of of that what's the connection there
so disproportionately the number of
people
who have been arrested and charged at
the rights that happen in portland um
have been disproportionately trammed in
some way
and so um i don't think that's
insignificant
because um unfortunately the
transgenderism has also become a
political ideology
in the united states and it's been very
very closely linked
to critical race theory and critical
race theory i think
taken to its logical conclusion leads
to people believing that the response to
political disagreements is violence for
example and threats and all that
so uh i think there's a link between a
and b
between why we're seeing so many trans
people and the other thing is
a lot of them it's on my view treat it
as sort of
a lot of them as you see are white and
they don't have a lot of
um identity markers that would make them
a
oppressed class of people but um to
suddenly
identify as trans um to be non-binary
for example
then they're suddenly you know queer uh
whereas
otherwise they would just be a
heterosexual white person
right otherwise in essence they would be
the very thing that they've come to hate
the most which
is a bizarre existential crisis i
suppose so
let's flash forward then to another year
so i saw you then in 2018 with jordan
then i saw you
in 2019 and then there was the the sort
of famous
incident when you got attacked can you
just uh recap that moment for people
that don't remember
so i was primarily known um
regionally in the pacific northwest
since 2017 for a lot of my coverage
of the antifa protests and riots and
that
eventually made me a target particularly
when i was coupling
my video coverage with
reporting and writing columns that were
getting published in some of these big
papers
and i was very clear in describing what
i
viewed as a violent extremist movement
that was veiling itself behind
social justice in carrying out acts of
violence against law enforcement and
private citizens in the city and for
that that made me
a target and in in june of 2019
when i was covering a protest turn right
in downtown portland
they saw an opportunity to
in a coordinated fashion beat me
multiple times on the head
it led to brain hemorrhage when i was
trying to walk away
they then threw all these liquids
in my face so i couldn't even see so
that's where the milkshaking
part came from um so i went on your show
i think about a month
after that and you could uh if you look
close because i started swelling and
a bit of a scab on my eye but it was a
brain injury that was most serious
and so um i had a whole year of various
medical treatments to address the
deficiencies that were caused as a
result of that
and what's tragic about all this is that
part of it was caught on video
it was literally in front of the justice
center which is the central police
precinct and the sheriff's office
not a single person has been arrested so
and if i remember correctly
at some point throughout that you you
sort of went to the police officers and
they didn't do anything right
yeah it was actually early in the day
because before people beat me in the
head a couple hours before they were
beginning to throw
their shapes at my head and all that and
uh i would walk to law enforcement who
are watching and i point out
this individual right here in that
colored backpack
just assaulted me uh i would like to
make a report
and i would like for you to identify
this person
because they're still right there and
the response every time
as it was then and afterwards and before
was always um that they wouldn't get
involved that they have been given
instructions to stay on the periphery
and to not step in um so
uh there's been a breakdown in
[Music]
not just morale police but like
the whole just rule of law period
uh in some of these places portland
seattle
it's like it i mean did you get the
response that police wanted to help more
than they could
because when i've been to some of these
things i always get the sense that
police wish they could do more we wish
that their leaders would allow them to
do more in other words
yes the beat cops i you know these are
the ones
who i have the most sympathy for but i
mean
policing you follow the chain of command
and police chiefs and captains and those
high up
uh in addition to being officers they're
also
politicians in a way because their
career as
you know the face of the police
department is a political position
and so you know that's why you were
seeing
police chiefs and um giving the knee
during some of these blm protests and
being so
deferential to these violent extremists
um because that's what's popular right
now so
um i think yeah leadership in these
urban areas have been wanting
uh also a lot of them wanted sheriffs as
well wanted to
vocally show that they were anti-trump
as well and that they were
pro the cause of racial justice
therefore
i think that affected the response from
law enforcement down but also there's
also initial resources as well
we've been having officers resign in
mass
and take early retirement as well and as
a
result
of that in many many american cities
there's just been a huge upsurge
in homicide shootings violence yeah i
mean we see this in almost
every progressive city and now we know
also that the new recruits i mean it's
like why would you want to go into law
enforcement if your mayors or your
governors
aren't going to have your back um you
know i know that just because i know you
personally i know
that some of the the sort of fame or
notoriety that this has come with
is not what you were looking for and
when i saw you that day you know a
couple weeks after you were attacked you
were obviously having
some uh some mental difficulties some
cognitive stuff that i'm thrilled to see
you're better obviously but you've sort
of become
part of the story which is a weird thing
for a journalist and
portland they they post about you you
know i mean quite literally things like
kill andy no i mean there are there are
awful things
the mobs that come after you online like
i get a lot of hate but your hate might
trump my hate
uh andy i i think it's possible can you
talk about that about just how
personally that's
been for you and how it sort of sucked
you in to the to the machine here
yeah so it's you know anti-fuss
extremism is not just their violence on
the streets
a huge part of their intimidation
is done through online or things that
are
borderline uh not illegal
such as showing up at people's homes
making it known that they know where you
live for example
writing your address
in public places um and write and kill
and murder
and you know um they wanted me to live
under like a constant fear
and um it's unfortunate that they
did succeed in that and because
at times when i was just carrying out
regular activities in life
like going to the gym or grocery
shopping one of their
members or sympathizers would recognize
me and post uh
and use some of these hashtags that
would then be reshared really quickly
with
the intended goal to sort of do a cyber
swarm
where through online information they
show up in real life to harass people
that's actually how they were able to
assault
ted wheeler one of them happened to see
him at a restaurant
so it's throughout 2020
i've been i was really on borrowed time
in portland
they had fully doxed me
threatened to kill me many times all
this is reported to
police and nothing ever happened
and so um did you ever try to escalate
it beyond
local portland police like did you ever
talk to the fbi or anything like that
i did report a lot of it to the fbi and
i never even heard back
they took an initial report and nobody
followed up with me
not even once god it's just
incredible so um let's talk a little bit
more about the the online component of
this
because i know finally in the last
couple weeks it looks like twitter did
remove a couple big
antifa accounts um we can all debate the
merits of free speech and whether they
were coordinating violence and and
all of that sort of thing but where else
are they
coordinating because i know when they if
i tweet something that's sort of against
antifa
and then i suddenly get literally
thousands of responses often telling me
to
go kill myself or they're going to come
get me or whatever whatever it might be
um that there's obviously some level of
coordination there's there are things
happening not just on twitter
do you know about those sort of networks
yeah it's all right about that in the
book
a lot of their organizing actually is
done
right and open through twitter and
being banned it's not really um
much of a handicap to them because these
accounts are all
anonymous anyways and they're plugged
until
they're connected to one another um
beyond twitter through things such as
signal and telegram
so when a major account is banned and
they open up just another one
immediately
that is announced through these channels
so then they immediately get new
followers
um but in portland in particular twitter
was the platform where most of the riot
organizing happened so you had like
all these ad hoc anti-flood groups that
popped up in the summer 2020 that
provided
um crap fundraise for riot gear
um food food was a big thing and not
insignificant because that
helped attract vagrants who
formed a big part of their part of their
units for rioting
um money for travel they went to other
cities there was
some of them who went to kenosha some of
them who went to dc
and all this was being done in the open
and on platforms like gofundme
um on cash app on demo and probably the
most successful campaign
in portland like minnesota was there was
a bail fund that was set up
so that immediately of the few people
who actually had bails
set because their charges were so
serious
they would immediately get bailed out
immediately and then the charges would
be dropped anyways
so they would get the money back and
they would reinvest that in other things
such as giving grants
to other anti-chapters so this is what i
mean this issue of allowing it to go on
so
long is that these systems and networks
will last
long beyond summer of 2020
and a lot of that unfortunately is also
out of the reach
of law enforcement such as the encrypted
communications that happen on signal or
telegram
right and we know that a whole bunch of
hollywood celebrities were promoting
those gofundmes to get these guys out
and am i
am i mistaken but didn't kamala harris
actually promote one
at one time she did she did i write
about that in the book so
um she tweeted out a link to her
millions of followers
for the minnesota freedom fund which was
the
group that paid the bail for accused
riders in minnesota
but it wasn't just rioters that were
being bailed out this organization was
also paying the bill for
accused murderers accused rapists
i mean just just staggering stuff what
about the relationship though with big
tech because obviously after the capitol
hill riots on the sixth
we know what happened with parlor their
servers were taken out by amazon
we know trump was banned by basically
everybody
um as i said before a couple antifa
accounts have been taken out
but they really do play footsie with
these things and as you just said
twitter is probably the main culprit
here
yes so um they've taken down a few
uh antiphon accounts but these are just
drops in the bucket
and rose city antifa is still on the
youth liberation front
is still on twitter and these are groups
that were instrumental
in years of violence in portland
um but the thing with big tech is um i
mean their bias is no secret i think
it's just it's the same thing with
journalism like
the r the staff the people who are
making up the workforce of these
large corporations they're largely
influential to excuse me sympathetic
to the cause of what they believe these
extremists are doing
right which then causes them to allow a
lot of this stuff to just slide while
on the other side they they certainly
wouldn't be as accommodating
um what do you think is sort of coming
with all of this because you know there
were a lot of people as 2020
ended there was a real feeling at least
in the mainstream media like oh
all right we got rid of trump you know
now
blm can calm down anti-fucking calm down
things will get better
clearly after the sixth and now
everything that we've seen in our 20
some odd days
of of january 2021 like it doesn't seem
like things are going to calm down
what do you think well it didn't calm
down in
starting in november november in
portland in response to
biden winning the people who took to the
streets weren't trump supporters in
portland they were antifa
and they marched around they just
severely damaged the church and they're
right there
the national guard was finally activated
for the first time that night
um too little too late in my view um
i think what's going forward is that
everything
is like the the past has already
been paid the mainstreaming of enough
tenants of their ideology
the allies that they've gained in
important institutions
have been made and of course then the um
the refined and perfected blueprints
for insurrection has also had it had
months and months of opportunity to
improve
so and establish itself so um
this whole i mean the whole pretext that
gave
antifa their meteoric uh
rise in 2016 was uh
in response to uh trump which they said
was the rise of
american fascism i mean that was
that was rubbish at that time it was a
lie
unfortunately they were um that argument
was given legitimacy through the
mainstream press
um but with trump out of the way
it's immaterial anyways because yeah
their opposition really is not too trump
as
to what to the united states and what
its founding ideals are
so these agitations to attack the us
will continue um and they've latched on
currently to
attracting law enforcement because
that's going to be around regardless of
what
administration would be in power yeah do
you think biden will do anything
with this i mean again this is where my
my frustration with the last few
liberals
is just it's totally out in the open i i
kept warning everybody like this isn't
gonna stop
this isn't gonna stop and now you have a
guy playing footsie with all of those
ideologies who's putting critical race
theory back into the system
so let's not pretend that he's going to
do anything to stop any of this stuff
bite into his credit has been very clear
when asked
about political violence he denounces it
but i mean
it's not but didn't he say antifa is
just an idea remember that
it's just an idea but let me but let me
qualify
my my praise of him it's i don't think
it's him who's really an
executive you can see it's the dnc yeah
so
you know when it when there was
inauguration day riots in
washington state and oregon um
by antifa gensake the the press
secretary was asked about that and she
didn't really have a response she didn't
condemn it either
i think like that lack of i guess more
clarity
so far by the administration is it's
like well
you know like they what these writers
were doing were very similar to what the
writers did
on the 6th of january but why do you not
treat it as important why does
administration
not view it as important so i mean like
antifa is just going to
be able to kind of go under the radar of
the mainstream
press and the administration in dc
as they're carrying out acts of carnage
continually and other
major american cities on the other part
of the country
yeah andy before we wrap here we should
talk a little bit about what happened at
that
bookstore in portland because your book
which comes out this week and again the
link to it is right below
uh you are selling i don't even know if
you have the numbers you don't have to
share them with me right now but
we know internally through the
publishing houses you're doing all right
at the moment the book
the book is taking off in many ways in
large part
to these crazy protests by the way
something very similar happened to me
back in april where they all coordinated
to ruin all my book
reviews but then that causes a backlash
and then people actually
read the book and they go oh this this
isn't that dangerous but in portland
uh they were protesting a bookstore uh
there was all sorts of stuff happening
over there can you just
tell people that story because it's just
it's just like a perfect little
microcosm of everything that's going on
here
yeah in january uh this year in response
to
um the book coming out soon the ansi
from portland
chose to surround and protest for six
days
portland's largest bookstore pals books
which is quite like an important like
institution in the city
and they weren't just it's not just
about them protesting the book who i
mean
who who cares that they don't like the
idea of it even though they haven't read
it
they were calling for it to be banned
and the bookstore partially
gave into that um they said that
they announced pre uh preemptively that
the book will not be
sold on any of the shelves but antifa
weren't happy with that because they
wanted it removed from the online
catalog
as well um i mean that was
not surprising surprisingly it's
disheartening it's disturbing to see
obviously
for you know modern people calling for
books to be banned even when they
haven't read them but i think
i guess the silver lining that is their
protest
help bring a lot of attention to this
book that was coming out
and so a lot of people weren't even
aware that uh
unmatched was coming out so i'm really
thankful to people who have
uh pre-ordered it so far and um you know
i'm really thankful that you allow me to
come on your show again and talk about
why this is so important and what this
book is about
yeah well andy i just want to say i'm
personally i'm thrilled for your success
i'm
beyond thrilled that you're healthy
again and that we have people like you
out there because i i know you from
years ago and you
you just wanted to do journalism where
in a time when everyone does
quote-unquote
journalism so i'm i'm glad you're doing
well i know you deal with a lot of
craziness in the midst of this whole
thing and i'm just
just seeing your successes is an example
that if you stand up for what you
believe in that that good things
can happen so uh listen people don't
burn this book
unmasked inside antifa's radical plan
to destroy democracy we've got the link
to it down below
and i look forward to seeing you again
my friend
thank you if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about the media instead of non-stop
yelling check out our media playlist and
if you want to watch full interviews on
a variety of topics check out the full
episode playlist
they're both right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell